(classical piano music)
- Boy you sure won that story.
Okay.
Thank you for tuning in to uh...
The Legends of Comedy.
(tape recorder clicks)
- That's was fantastic.
You did a great job.
There were a lotta hard
hitting questions in there.
- Well you wrote them.
You wrote all of 'em.
Can I ask you something
off the record?
- Absolutely.
(tape recorder clicks)
- Why do you have an
intern interview you
about your comedy career?
Couldn't you have
a friend do it?
- I'm an adult.
I don't have friends.
- Gotta love that friend, right?
The friend who
doesn't pay his taxes?
If you're thinking about
your own friend group,
you can't figure out who it is.
Uh. Spoiler alert.
It might be you.
(audience laughs)
So pay your taxes. Okay.
It's easy. It's so easy.
The form is called 1040 E-Z.
Alright?
Line number one...
Income.
Wages, salaries and tips.
Hey I got a tip for ya
- Glad I devoted
my life to this.
(audience laughs)
- pay your taxes. Okay.
- [TV Comedian] Get
a load of this guy.
(phone beeps)
What a ya gonna do?
(audience laughs)
Deduct those nachos?
(loud music)
(phone chimes)
(phone beeps)
- [Comedian] 1040!
- [Audience] E-Z!
(phone beeps)
- [Comedian] 1040!
- [Audience] E-Z!
(phone beeps)
- [Comedian] 1040!
- [Audience] E-Z!
- 1040!
- Ya gotta pay your
taxes everybody!
(audience cheers loudly)
- See the reality it is.
Oil is sold in dollars
globally, right?
And that's what keeps
our currency having
purchasing power.
People complain about wars.
But
that's the only thing that
maintains our way of life.
Ya know.
- Cool cool cool.
Congrats man.
Listen, I gotta
grab a new drink.
- But the...
(soft music)
Actually, I should probably...
(bottle top opens)
Relax.
It's not like it's
coming outta your pocket.
(soft music)
Hey Errol.
You made it.
- Yeah. Just got here.
- Cool. I'll...
I'm glad you're feeling...
- Oh! David!
How you doin' my man?
I'd shake but I got my
hands full with $20 bourbon
and hot babe ass.
Right babe?
She's mad because I
won't buy her a drink.
What're you workin' on?
- Um, thinkin' of launching
a Twitter parody account.
- [Man] Ugh!
- Maybe, Vine.
- Ooh!
Well, ya know it's alright man.
It takes time for some people.
I mean, look at uh
Judge Judy.
87 years old got the
number one show on TV.
Two hundo mill duh-lor-ez
And all she does is decide
who pays the electric bill.
That could be you.
- Yeah. You're right.
- I'm wearin' a $1000 suit,
you're wearing a
performance fleece.
You don't have to
tell me I'm right.
I know I'm right.
Right babe?
(slow music)
I don't think she
speaks English.
Ever hear of Stevie Wonder?
- Yeah
- Would you believe that
that guy never learned
how to read music?
- Wow that's impressive.
- Yeah I know.
I only say things
that are impressive.
I'm gonna go talk to
somebody over here.
(light piano music)
(phone clicks and tones)
(phone buzzes)
(phone beeps)
(phone chimes)
- Hmm.
(light piano music)
Good time.
(metal clanging)
- Same time next week.
- No.
I got a another Craigslist job.
It's a little more dignified.
- What is it?
- Nude house cleaner.
(birds chirping)
- I tell ya.
Nothin's ea--